[Music]
if you haven't posted in a year and now
you're trying to post to all the
platforms
that could be
a huge trap i love for now stuff if you
never do for now then you get stuck of
going another year without making
content right you can provide a real
value to business owners and also help
grow your company at the same time
oh my goodness there he is
how you doing orlando
not bad yourself i'm great man so
orlando's part of movement makers and as
part of that we're doing uh ig live
together so
what's on your mind man how can i help
yeah so literally about a year ago right
i started with movement makers and you
inspired me to get a video out that day
and i did and that's the only video i
got on youtube is that one video
so
i think the theme of
this one one is uh getting started again
so kind of hit me reset button
uh i have an intern this summer
uh
and what we're doing right now is uh
we're taking a lot of the interviews
that i've taken or the video already
have so i've done videos and interviews
with
different hosts and different shows and
different programs and that we're going
through that and editing it
for the purpose of publishing it or
repurposing it
funny enough i saw
your comment recently when you're doing
a live ask me anything and you mentioned
you know uh making smaller pieces of
that long piece is not going to do much
for you i was like oh darn
but it's where i'm at right now right so
i have something we can edit we can
start publishing it the idea was taking
that long piece of content publishing on
linkedin and then having smaller pieces
to post on uh formatted correctly and
and and cut well for the consumption on
linkedin facebook instagram and maybe
even tick tock so that's what we're
going to try to do five five different
platforms
go long first and then repurpose for
each of those other platforms in a way
that for example an instagram you know
daily post
you know to get it out there um that's
where i'm at right now that's what we're
doing but um i
you can comment on that if you like to
kind of talk about where i'm at
and what's your thoughts on that but i i
also like in this call to cover um some
practical things kind of getting started
again of like okay let's just do step
one step two step three break it down
for me again and say look ideally about
where you orlando this is how i want you
to take action
this is the first thing through whatever
step five whatever it is
and go like more of a approach thing
cool so
to start
cutting up the videos for micro content
to the to the other platforms is great
okay for youtube not so much you can do
it for youtube shorts which is a
relatively new feature so you can do
that but for for
you know youtube loves long form video
so it won't work as well for regular
youtube content but definitely cutting
it up for the other platforms makes a
ton of sense which by the way says i had
no
lead magnet or anything else the call to
action would be simply to bolster the
youtube channel and have people watch
the full
version of it in the youtube channel
that's the best thing i can come up with
right now since i don't have more
content or a lead magnet
great so you use it for now you know i
mean the i i love for now stuff
right like because otherwise if you
never do for now then you get stuck of
going another year without making
content right right so for now it was
fine just
it's for now and we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna get better and we're gonna
keep so having a lead magnet will be
important for the business right and
that's ultimately we're gonna drive
people to
um but for now yeah momentum like that's
what's really missing
so what
to give you like a practical plan you
can stick to what prevented you
from making more content in the past
year
yeah there's um
at every stage of getting something out
the door i was stuck so for example on
the theme of what to talk about there
was that problem and some of the quick
answers is hey throughout the day
someone asked me a question
uh then take that and just make an
answer and put it out
problem is if i'm looking for an ideal
10 minutes or more in content for again
starting with youtube first and then
repurposing out
um it just takes a little bit more work
in my mind with
okay how do i fill that up because i
like to give succinct answers obviously
to a real person who doesn't want to sit
there for 10 minutes with one question
then i got to go through the formula
then then again the next thing right
happens okay so what's the formula let
me break it down let me come up with my
um my my shocking kind of statement my
my hey let me stop you the tracks um
thought uh thought leader lead and then
go through and fill out each of those
it's just
it was like pretty hard i think for me
um the next thing is i was thinking okay
well um in order to do that maybe i need
to do some research and i go down the
rabbit hole like okay maybe some data
maybe some you know it's like then done
and nothing happens so what's missing is
the for now
okay right so just do a two minute
answer put it up or whatever it lands
right now
okay like a two minute answer uh you
know once a week is better than nothing
for a year yeah
so this is our for now because like
anything else the as you get more
practice as you get more into it it
becomes easier and and then you're ready
to take the next step
if you're trying to learn like if you're
trying to learn english you start with
some common words and some basic you
know grammar structure because if you
through them the entire dictionary to
remember they're not going to get it
it's just too difficult right so you
layer things on as you go so worrying
about the perfect research topic or
having the powerful opinion and all like
that's it becomes overwhelming
i know you don't do anything and this
isn't just orlando this is everybody so
so it's fine so it's creating the same
mindset of for now like you're doing on
the other platforms
because if you haven't posted here's a
concern if you haven't posted in a year
i'm less concerned about like reigniting
the audience or what are people going to
think like forget about that it's just
more
if you haven't posted in a year and now
you're trying to post to all the
platforms
that could be
a huge trap because it becomes
overwhelming to have to post
everywhere and maintain that system
right
so uh if you have somebody helping you
amazing but the most important thing is
we need to get some consistent content
going out you were doing business
brokering yep yep so i'm a business so
aspira is the brand and we have a
business brokerage buying and selling
privately held businesses 20 million
below so we do main street low middle
market kind of m a or intermediary work
and we also have the real estate
brokerage uh which um the broker of
record
uh on that company which is a separate
uh company under the brand and that's
commercial residential mostly investment
stuff and of course they complement each
other because a lot of business owners
also own the real estate they need
advice on you know all that kind of
stuff
and then the third is advisory that's
you know partly personally investing and
having an investment partner sign up
whatever lp's you you know just
there's or fee um fee services including
uh what's the valuation of the business
okay here's a fee for
uh telling you what your most probable
sales prices of your business in today's
market things like that so those are
three major
um divisions of a spirit
so if somebody's trying to sell their
business
i mean you've done it so many times but
for a lot of people it's their first
time
they they they have a lot of questions
before they just sign up with you and go
through the process right
yep
so what's a common question that they
would ask
yeah so if i could take that what you're
saying and take it as a theme
so i think as a whole bracket of
questions you're first saying look uh
come up with things that will help with
the flow of my business so onboarding a
business owner first of all even
answering prospects questions or
frequently asked questions and then
maybe even ask another category of um
should ask questions anything they even
think about asking that that kind of
lead into that
and then even with buyers right so
buyers looking at businesses for sale we
we you know of course respond to them
that might be another category you're
coming up with a whole bunch of video
ideas now for your channel right yeah
i'm trying to think big picture more
systemically so i can just kind of like
break it down and just get to it um but
yeah so you know in terms of the
business owners looking to sell their
business
you know the three major categories
again just kind of high level is you
know is my business sellable
um how much can my business sell for and
what's the process look like so every
time i consult with a person who's
looking to sell their business that's
how i set the agenda for the call i said
there's anything else they say nope that
covers everything i need to know and we
can we just jump right in okay so if
somebody's going to come into your
office and say hey first off you already
have now these are all video topics so
your whole like researching what do you
that's what you talk about
is my business sellable
how long does the process take how much
can i get from my business these are all
videos where are people going to learn
how to do this yeah
right like there's nobody they're going
to learn from you they're going to learn
from your videos
so if you take a question like that so
now we already have a list of ideas that
you can make content on like those are
the easiest kinds of videos to make
because you answer those questions day
in day out
helping people
somebody comes into your office and says
hey orlando is my business sellable
are you just going to give a two minute
answer for them and then say thank you
and kick them out
uh actually on that portion without the
questions i have asked i have to ask
them
i i try to keep their two three minutes
to give them really in a nice little
succinct
hey you know this is what you need to
understand about making a business
sellable so if you own your business
and i can go through those two three
minutes with you but you know i do i
stop there and then i you know i i can
you know and then i have some questions
for that but i can of course cover those
questions leave those as perhaps some
some food for thought for anybody who's
watching the video
and i guess i could put a third
component to that um i need your help
here can get a little stuck but a third
component to make it go to 10 minutes or
so whatever eight minutes or six minutes
i'm guessing i could probably add in
there um
you know uh something about being
prepared for a call and just having this
information what you need
um but that's probably about it i'm
thinking right now in terms of how to
get that bigger but that's so help me
through this i'm stuck on that yeah
again so first off like
for now if it's a two minute video or
five minute video go like that's it for
now let's get it going
um to make it longer just imagine what
happens when somebody's coming into your
office and wants to sell their business
and doesn't know if if they if they're
big enough how much how much are the
fees how like they just don't know the
process they've never done it before
that meeting is going to last a total of
how long
with you
uh to cover those three items uh with
the back and forth in roughly 20 minutes
or so
so they're going to come in they're
going to talk for 20 minutes and they're
going to leave your office no most of
the consults are by phone like
somebody's going to call you that call
you've never you've never met them
before they're you're going to
they're going to say hey i want to sell
my business orlando i don't know the
process
that call lasts 20 minutes typically
uh yeah i mean it can go of course
longer if we're going to the next step
and we're going further but uh but yeah
so
that's what that's what the video
becomes like it doesn't mean the video
has to be 20 minutes but
you say something well that's that's
only because you're answering questions
and it usually takes longer for them to
answer questions than it is for me to
kind of get my part yeah like it's the
same call
every time pretty much right like
there's some minor there's just some
minor differences but you know what
they're going to ask when they call you
that's the same eight questions they
lead with and then it's the same 20
questions afterwards that you just know
how to answer because it keeps coming up
over and over so
when somebody's on a call with you
you give them the space to ask the
question that you know they're going to
ask anyway right they're like pick a
pick from this bag of questions you know
they're going to ask it but you give
them the space to ask it in a video
where it's just one way
there's no space for them to ask a
question
right i mean they could leave a comment
and you asked but what you want to do
is
answer the next questions for them
because you already know what their
follow-up questions are going to be
so you take the question you take the
video further down the path by answering
their next question so you can still
keep it to two minutes three minutes
okay so is my business sellable well
here's what you have to think about
three-minute answer done now you may be
asking
whatever the next question is right so
you already know what they're going to
ask next just bring that into the video
as if you're having a conversation but
you have to bring the questions because
there's no way to interact with you
while you're recording
yeah
it doesn't mean you have to go all the
way to 20 minutes or half an hour or if
they're with you 45 minutes or whatever
but
imagine doing their role play okay
you've just said this stuff and this is
easier for you because you've already
had all these conversations it's not
like you have to imagine a fictitious
conversation you're already having this
all the time when people come and call
your office
so just take the conversation further
and and play both sides
so you may be asking
well how do i know if it's the right fit
for me
and then you may be asking well how much
does this cost and how long does it take
it's like all of the questions that
people will ask you each time
that's how you can make the video longer
and and not just longer because of
youtube algorithm but like more value to
like if you just answer the question in
three minutes and then shut it down
they're left with maybe more questions
than answers like okay but what about
this this this this and this
right
answer those questions for them on the
video yeah
which by the way is another thing i'm
getting mired into a little bit is um
using the smaller pieces to create
bingeable content to start those
algorithms
so is that is that even correct where
basically if you can get through a
minute or two minutes or three minutes
of something it says to answer the next
question or whatever to cover that topic
and then have a little card click the
next one and watch the next two three
minute video
and is that would that help as a
strategy to do it that way where they
kind of watch a second video of mine on
youtube it definitely works i would just
try to make every video longer
again for now you go and you make it
but then try to make those ten minute
videos instead of three minute videos
the other way around it is to tell a
story and stories
stories sell and stories also help make
it more
helps pass the understanding on
makes it easier for people to consume
and digest
so if somebody comes and asks you hey
how do i sell my business you can go
give your three-minute answer
and then say for example i had i had
somebody come in and you can change you
don't say the person's name or the
industry or the name of the company or
or whatever or you could
do a hypothetical like so for example
you know if you're a restaurant and
you're trying to sell your business
and then you explain it through the
example of the restaurant
yeah i like that that's great
have a story and an example for
everything that you're sharing like when
you have somebody in front of you you're
probably already doing this anyway
through their business if
somebody comes you and they have an auto
dealership like hey orlando help me sell
my auto dealership you're going to tell
the story through the lens of an auto
dealership
just naturally because that's you're not
going to tell some story of a
of a bakery or something right
it's an auto dealership but when
somebody's watching a video again you
have no idea what industry they're in
so be able to give an example
for a lot of people it's it's their
first time and it's confusing and
overwhelming they don't know what to do
next so giving them an example can help
so okay so let's say you're a bakery and
you're trying to sell your bake shop
here's what here's what we would need to
know
and so you can now emphasize the points
and explain the points that you just
made in the three first three minutes
through the use of an example of a real
client or a fake client or made up
client would you recommend
um
let's say that first video we're talking
about here it's it's however long we
have stories in there so it's looking
good and it's really engaging um having
those time stamps
in the description so that they can go
okay
0.1 and then story example 4.1 and then
like break it down like that is that
helpful
so i'll take this answer in like two
ways
one way to answer the question is no i
haven't we've done a whole bunch of
testing and haven't proven that it works
a lot of people use it as a best
practice but i haven't seen any data
that show that it leads to more
retention on the video in fact often it
leads to less retention because people
skip ahead to the next thing um
so i wouldn't i'm not recommending it
and i'm not doing it um
but the second path of that question is
like dude it doesn't matter make videos
right
like all of the questions that are
basically getting in the way of making
content of having a perfect structure
and format and how youtube works when
when nothing is going up so that's the
like it's it's good for now and keep
creating keep posting keep making and
then you take it through your three
sides of the business right if the third
one i think you said was business
valuations how much is my business worth
advisory yeah
yeah so you're not going to sell it but
you're going to you're going to you're
going to evaluate their business yeah
it's mostly investment advisory uh as
well as just the fee based stuff yeah so
investment advisory includes like
investing together so maybe putting
content out there you're talking about
working together on investment
opportunities
yeah so how to find the right
opportunity
what factors what are the main factors
to look at you have a you have a process
you have your methodology it may not be
like fully written out or maybe it is
but you have you have the certain
questions that you ask
when you're looking at making investment
so like that's another video and then
make an example so for example if i was
looking at buying a software company
here's what i want to look at
right and then maybe you throw a second
example because the software company
might have a higher valuation have a
higher multiple because they're more
profitable than a bakery
so for example then if i but if i wanted
to buy a bakery it'd be looking at these
and so in like making making the
examples happen it makes it a lot more
clear for people watching and also
extends the video
so so you sparked another idea which is
to do industry-specific videos
so
do kind of a similar thing but really
talk about
uh florist um
talk about bakers like you said you know
talk about auto body shops talk about
pizzerias
as a business and then
basically make a video talking about
that so pizzeria owners this is what
you're dealing with i understand kova
did this to you you're doing really well
but you have to understand you know all
that was just really giving give the
business owners um
advice
to that particular market so getting
niched down in content i guess is that
that's the idea that i kind of walked
away with that one
the last comment was more if it's a more
broad one
that to give a couple examples because
if you're doing if you're doing multiple
of earnings however you evaluate in the
business a software company should look
dramatically different than a bake shop
right for how much the company's gonna
be worth and what multiple we're taking
so if you're gonna give a general like
how much is my business worth
you can talk for a couple minutes on it
but then it also depends on the industry
that you're in where then you can give a
couple examples so that's a video
if you want to do industry specific
videos how do i evaluate a pizza shop
how do i evaluate a bake shop how do i
evaluate a car dealer yeah those could
all work too
those i would try to find i would i
would make videos around the companies
that you actually want to invest in like
if you have no interest in buying pizza
shops then don't make pizza videos yeah
if you love software companies then make
videos about because then we start
attracting the right people in
because ultimately your goal is not to
be a huge youtuber or influencer like we
need more business coming in
right you're trying to get deal flow
yeah
which is for which is fine which is fair
so like let's optimize for that
yeah although um i i think you know one
thing i realize is you have to be
intentional about what we're doing and
visualizing where the end looks like and
and
trying to it helps to kind of pull you
in the right direction and so
i was telling you my intern today we
were just meeting and i mentioned that
look i let's active with the intention
of doing the best things we can do to
get to two million subscribers on a
youtube channel but give us the break
and and no stress that pressure knowing
that we're starting from some place
and then in video 10 or 50 50 when i
look back at video one and be
embarrassed by it which is you know some
things you mentioned many times but i i
was thinking that uh at least i was
motivated today about look let's make
that effort as if okay and and that just
ups the standard in terms of where we're
going and hopefully accelerates our
iterative iterative learning that was my
uh my thought for today
yeah i honestly wouldn't worry about
upping the standard yet right again like
there's nothing on there so we don't
worry there's nothing so what are we
raising a standard on right like so
iterative yes right so like okay we made
our first video it's two minutes now
let's make it better for the next one
and yeah for sure
um but i think the ultimate goal would
be to how can we how can we use youtube
to grow
your business and get more leads coming
in and just educate people a lot more
and what it takes to
build a valuable company that then you
can sell and what your options are
afterwards whether they end up hiring
you or not but we're putting out you
know like that's a that's an important
topic
it's probably not a 2 million subscriber
channel like if you're gonna go
you want to hit 2 million subscribers
now we got to dive more into mindset and
habits and routines and
more like hidden all of america
which maybe becomes an ambition but
you've got a real opportunity and
expertise inside of what you do
and people aren't making enough content
on it that
you can provide a real value to to
business owners and also help grow your
company at the same time
yeah
so i would just think like what are the
what are the questions people ask you
consistently
answer that question and then tell even
that your basic it's like it's you're
going to give your statement and tell
the story
and that's it for now don't worry about
like all the the perfect format and
template and
lead magnet and we'll get there
right for now
yeah yeah for now is like the theme of
this call for now we're doing it for now
it's a you're teaching me something and
then you tell me a story about it
and that becomes a content that you put
out consistently that then you can bring
to the other platforms as well
yeah
so just just basically for now try to
get to 50 or 100 video posts and
content and then figure out from there
what to do with it
there's a lot you could do with it
afterwards right but like we just don't
have enough orlando content to do
anything with
yeah
so all of those could win hard on
linkedin like linkedin should be huge
for you
yeah
for getting business tick tock maybe i
mean tech talk i wouldn't concern myself
with as much but linkedin for sure even
twitter could be a good spot for you
and the same video you could post like
you just make it 45 seconds and then you
post a twitter you post to linkedin
you know take take little clips
but it's just getting orlando in front
of a camera and pressing the cord
and do do 10 at a time like you just sit
there in your chair and you just make 10
videos
because the energy it takes to like make
one video you can then go and make five
more right after right
right
okay
um
and in terms of i mean everything else i
imagine i already know the answer in
terms of those steps step one is
uh coming with some topics to to record
content we covered that
and then the rest really doesn't matter
i guess the answer is it really doesn't
matter just
record it doesn't matter about how you
break it down doesn't matter how long it
is does it doesn't matter about editing
it just publish it if you know just get
it out there
yeah honestly the editing and the the
steps
uh
matter even less because
you know what you're doing like you know
if you didn't know the answer to those
questions then that's a big problem
right if somebody walks in if the video
is about how do you evaluate your
business and you don't know how to
evaluate a business
that's a big problem
like i can't i mean i can't help you
with that one you have to know your
industry
but that's why people are watching
they're not watching you because you
have fancy editing and lower thirds and
music and b-roll of somebody climbing up
a mountain and
you know like that's not why those those
work but that's not why i'm watching
your video
you have knowledge it's getting out of
here and in into the world
and people will watch that because they
want to learn so
i wouldn't be so concerned about how
many steps are in each video
um because just talk like you would
imagine someone's in front of you and
has that question just talk to them like
you would talk to them
you know the other problem that i have
in my head is i just feel like i don't
want to listen to myself like i i
that's just what's in my head like i
don't know if i want to listen to that
so i get stuck with like okay is that
even worth you know publishing and then
listen after this call you know
the last call was uh just get that one
video out right this call you're asking
me to do is look just produce produce
i'll produce and i'll put it out there
but i'm gonna i know i'm gonna have the
feeling that it's all like stuff that i
wouldn't even spend 20 minutes listening
to like for 10 minutes
but it's true you wouldn't
i don't want to spend 20 minutes
watching myself either
but you already know this stuff like
here's the thing people call you and
they want to spend 20 minutes talking to
you
you're not making a video for you you're
making a video for your your your
audience your customers like i don't
want to hear myself talk
so don't don't let that be the um
how you judge it
yeah
you should not want to watch it right
like this is this is it's stuff you
already know you're not learning
anything you're not learning anything
but you're teaching i mean i'll take
that to answer my other problem which is
you know i i look at it and so that
wasn't quite well succinct i was a
little you know just talking too much
about it because it's like okay you're
boring like just if you get the subject
matter the way you delivered it but
that's just a matter of just practice
that's a matter of looking at it again
okay now i have a better angle of coming
at it and just you know just go so that
answers that question as well
the answer to everything is for now for
now just just yeah it's boring for now
like maybe it is boring but even in your
boring it's still valuable
because who else is talking about this
stuff
so it's still useful for people yeah
yeah i really want to make it more
entertaining like there's this guy
called law by mike on tick tock who has
millions of freaking viewers and he's
taking law and making it interesting but
it's crazy production over there it's
about production he's got these
different cuts he is giving himself a
haircut he's the police officer and you
know stopped pulling himself over i mean
it's hilarious there's a lot of
production into it uh so i'm not sure if
tick tock's just a different angle but
but i
i really just want to entertain i really
want to make it
you know
fun and and engaging
so you can but for now we got to get
going it's like it's like an
entrepreneur comes to you and says
orlando i want to i want to sell my
business for 10 million
cool
where you at now nothing
you got to get going dude right like
that's i love it like having inspiration
is fantastic can you work towards
building that 100
and for now
you just got to get going
okay
for now this is it for now this is it
for and and then yes iterate and raise
your standards and keep keep pushing
your intern or your team to do and keep
pushing yourself to do better but not at
the expense of a video not going up
right so like every week a video has to
go up
and then inside of that let's try to
make it better but don't try to make it
so good that then nothing gets created
right
right so at this point i think for my
own self um
i gotta remind myself but i'm not
embarrassed and i took too long to get
it out
i gotta just feel embarrassed get it out
go and
and and see what happens and so is it
just for now yeah
in terms of getting you know with with
the topics we talked about you recommend
starting with uh talking to
creating content for the business owners
looking to sell
or it doesn't really matter just
whatever inspires go yeah we're like who
do you want to attract who do you want
to be picking up the phone and calling
you out of your three divisions i mean
it could be all three but who do you
want to call you
and then make videos targeting them so
like if you don't want big shops to call
you to sell their business don't make
content around bake shops
i kind of want it all and if i can i'm
also looking to recruit so i i need to
create content around that too i think
there's a lot of stuff to do i guess i
just got to get started just you know
maybe write them all out and then pick
one out of a hat and just go
you don't even i mean we already talked
about like four different ideas plus in
here you think about your three
divisions and you already had it like
there are these questions cool and i'll
just tack a story on the end of each one
how to evaluate my business great teach
me for three minutes and then tell me a
story
next
okay
don't worry about the rest of it don't
worry about that intro
tell me about the hook well for now we
will we will but like not at the expense
of videos not going up yeah get those
out for now
and then we'll worry about intro and
worry about length and more about league
magnet and and listen after you worry
about that there's more stuff to worry
about too and then even more stuff to
worry about too you're like you're like
the startup entrepreneurs like how do i
how am i gonna raise the venture capital
to hire like the big ceo i wanna hire
like the former ceo of disney to run my
company
dude you haven't started what are you
doing right like we need you need to get
let's get to ten thousand dollars in
revenue first you know but and then a
hundred and then a million and then
right so all of that stuff will matter
and you could be the next doctor whoever
lawyer guy awesome yes
that could happen
but not if you're not making content
right so it's like the basics first and
then you build on those once the basics
become easy
like if you can't come up with video
topics yet and press record nothing else
will matter
so you get the basics down and that
might happen fast maybe you do like a
month of those like wow this is so much
easier than i thought cool now you now
we add in whatever the next level is if
it's lead magnet or longer videos or
better intros or cards at the end or
right if you had just started a year ago
and kept going we'd be having a
different conversation by now
yeah a much more advanced conversation
right
and that's not to like
no yeah
that's just this is where we're at right
but cool so like between now and next
year
that's the difference and then we'll be
having a different conversation and
that's that's amazing and it's beautiful
but it's you getting that
if whether it's like i'm gonna be
embarrassed and just post cool or just
tell yourself this is it for now and
then i'm gonna we're gonna get better
and in a month and two months and three
months will be better and not have the
burden of perfection
or the burden of we have to build a two
million subscriber channel or the burden
of like making it look super
entertaining yet
right
you can get there
yeah
okay
it's more the same i did it i get it all
right time to make videos orlando thank
you all right thank you again appreciate
you man we'll see you soon
okay take care
yeah here's part of our movement makers
program as part of that we're doing a ig
live together so
what do you got first uh thank you very
much for uh having like the honor to
join the group it's amazing also the
book
love it
i wanted to ask a few questions on uh
opening a new youtube channel
which i'm planning to do
a long time already but uh and then also
i i have a question then i know we're
short in time but i really appreciate it
so
basically when i open i'm not really a
technology guy now when i open a new
channel
how do i get my native uh
language is not english but i want to do
it in english
how do i get people
uh to my channel if i'm not like really
a social media guy and i'm not in those
worlds my goal is to
light people's path and give them a
feeling of empowerment and belonging and
what is the business model ultimately
like you want to sell coaching or what
what do you right now i'm not selling
coaching in the future maybe i'll do
that but now my goal is 100 just helping
people by i believe i'll stay in two
seconds if you invest it's going to be
called invest and smile
so if you invest in six areas of life
uh your life your path will light and uh
you'll smile
i like it dude okay so
and then but where does that go is that
a course is that a book is that a speech
like where is it right now only to help
people like their path
uh
in the future maybe i'll take it for
coaching but i'm not
i'm not looking to yeah
okay is coaching interesting for you i
don't know in the long run i love
coaching uh also now people sometimes
come for me like if you're asking my
vision i could also see like having
seminars weekends and like that that's
doing in the long run maybe also a book
but i'm saying step by step right now
i'm thinking about it too much for a
long time because i'm thinking maybe i'm
not credible enough or things like that
so first i just want to start sure okay
so uh but i would start down two
parallel paths the first is
you have your six six steps to having
happiness right
so your videos are all about
one of those six steps
so each time you make a video it's got
to touch one of those six steps and in
terms of making content it could be from
your own story your own background your
like how you got there like history
stuff like way back of who you are and
where you came from we're telling
stories from our past
um it could be stories from your present
you know how did you pick that plant
behind you and and why is there like a
yellow
you know rainbow on your wall and like
i'm assuming they're there for some
reason in intention um
your thoughts coming into doing this
instagram live together uh how does it
touch on one of the six points
in your happiness chart and so we're
only six points right i mean i say the
same stuff over and over yeah it's kind
of six points but if you just let me
i'll explain it so basically i believe
that if the mind is in the middle but if
you invest in the mind relationships uh
movement activity uh sleep nutrition and
relationships so that will light your
path so every time it's going to be a
different one i'm not going to do all of
them and i don't want it to do only for
my stories because i also listen to a
lot like i learned from you i learned
like i'm only one person i also want to
bring from other places but how how do i
get to people like no one knows
like i don't want to put out tons of
money in
marketing before i started doing
anything
so in the content i agree you don't want
to have a video that talks about all six
things unless you just you can have a
video that explains the
the you know the six things in general
like here's my philosophy but then the
future videos are diving more specific
on each one but basically everything
you're going to make i s i have the same
10 to 20 themes that i talk about on
repeat
but i have different stories that i'll
use depending on what's going on so you
have your six themes
and you can have different stories that
you talk about depending on what's going
on it doesn't only have to be about you
i'm just saying you is important because
it's your it's your framework right so
in terms of kinds of stories to tell
it's from the past foundation stories
but also new stuff that's coming up
right now something's gonna happen this
week that can fit into one of your six
things that you can make a video on
um
then we can also make content about
other people in something in the news
that you see and that you like or don't
like or somebody you know an experience
you had in movie makers or with a fellow
movement maker a live stream that you
did with somebody else right that
becomes a story this is like how do you
take what's going on in the world not
just your world but the world
and make it make sense in terms of one
of the six areas of
of content
the reason why i suggested coaching if
you liked it is
you don't have to get paid at the
beginning like if you're worried about
your experience and credibility you
don't know what the answer is going to
be he doesn't have to be coaching yet
you just be conversations
you basically walk people through
the six steps and wherever they're
struggling the most you have you have a
conversation around it
which then eventually leads to more
expertise which leads to more you know
could actually become coaching could
then become something paid could then
become a book or a seminar or something
else but
when you're creating content in a vacuum
meaning if it's just you
talking to the camera you don't know how
well your thoughts are being received or
how to adjust them
but when you're talking to somebody look
here example look okay our arcano just
wrote six areas
what are the six areas again here
yeah mine mind movement
relationships nutrition sleep
and i'm missing right now one of them
my movement relationship is sleep
i just gotta black out but okay
okay well listen so that if that's at
the core then the next
financial behavior financial behavior
so that needs to be printed somewhere so
that you know you remember it and you
can refer back to it
and you can also give it to other people
and and what happened right there when
when they asked the question
what are the six areas
you don't have to be i mean you should
know what they are is fine but but like
you don't have to be the expert on all
those things yet you can just talk about
what you're doing and what you've seen
with those things
but the more you have the conversations
and the more you start helping people
the discussions
can become
coaching or mentoring
at the beginning it's not right at the
beginning it's just going to be
a conversation but in having those
conversations like if if he says
so we said those six areas
maybe somebody like somebody's even
mind movement relationships sleep
financial and blocking out no that was
uh what was my
movement sleep nutrition relationships
and
financial behavior nutrition yes i'm
used to saying in my own language in
english it's uh
different
that's great yeah i mean and and that's
awesome and so now he's saying thank you
right maybe he has a follow-up question
maybe he says well what do you what do
you mean by mind
and then you explain what you mean by
mind
and then maybe that leads to another
question and you don't have to have all
the answers yet because it's not a it's
not a paid coaching session
but it's a discussion that as people ask
questions it makes your model better
it makes the framework better
so i would be trying to do
videos with people talking about
different
elements of those of that framework
right an easy one is already within
mover makers to do the challenge that we
do every month
i'm learning how to use discord uh me
and technology are still learning how to
work with each other i didn't have
instagram until the second i just
downloaded because
i knew i needed for now
there you go
and you made it happen so it's great but
i mean that
somewhere inside of mind you know
there's there's the answer every month
in movement makers you there's a
challenge that we do
and as a theme and part of that theme is
then doing your own video on that topic
but then also three collaboration videos
with other people makers
so if the theme is gonna be you know
confidence or consistency or resilience
or whatever right um
you know if you take confidence as the
theme
then
how does confidence fit into
one of those six things and you have a
conversation about it
and every time you talk about it
the the model becomes clearer
yeah for sure i understand that and i i
really appreciate the fact you know that
there's a community uh i think that's
amazing i didn't think about that
uh
and what i want to do in the future is
also have interviews because i do i i
chose those six steps through things
that went in life but
there are people that are experts uh so
let's say i was in real estate i didn't
know how to take the hammer and build
the wall or do drywall but like knowing
to bring the people to talk about this
stuff so i think what you said the
combination between
right the beginning talking to other
people and then also bringing every time
maybe an expert later on but my first
question is how how do people know it
all i exist like you're saying
in the beginning don't care about that
like just talk to people in the
community and like how do i reach out to
people
almost by the nature like if people
don't know who you are and you're
reaching out and then you get something
then you get people to follow right
yeah sure by making content if it's good
content and people want more of that
good content so i mean movie makers is
your easiest start
that
they will go live with you
they'll get like just like that we're
going live right now you set up your
account people are now learning about
you if they like the the six steps or
they like you or they want to learn more
about your journey they can now follow
your account and find out more about you
right at the beginning i wouldn't i
wouldn't um like the biggest thing is
just momentum
it's just creating
and the more you can create with other
people the better because it allows you
to refine your thinking a little bit
more
so i would do a mix of collaborations
and and
the challenge is only three people right
coach queen kelly says i'll go live with
you appreciate that there you go
go go
remember coach queen kelly and and send
her a message i learned how to do that
right like but that's it but you can
learn that i mean nobody knows any of
the platforms at the beginning you
figure it out as you go you didn't know
anything about nutrition either and you
didn't know anything about finance
either you didn't know anything about
the mind either and how did you learned
it right uh yeah
so same thing
instagram is
is you already figured it out look you
started you just created your account
today when we went live like the camera
was facing backwards you know
and now we're here you're already better
than me
yesterday right that's how learning's
that's how the learning goes
um in our challenge in movie makers
which
the requirement is to do three people
but i would
a lot more more sure
but
when you say when you say evan like your
video so
when i do a video i could put also on my
youtube channel and also on instagram or
you don't recommend to do it on both
i would do both for now
honestly because it's just momentum you
don't you just set up your instagram
account you you don't have a youtube
channel it's just about getting stuff up
to to
know what it's like to get stuff up like
just to build the it's like you're
asking for the perfect workout plan
and you haven't done a push-up
you're just sitting on the couch right
and so it's
in terms of movement what's the perfect
movement plan
how about you start with a walk outside
right like if movement's one of your
things and somebody's been sitting on
the couch their entire life and they
want a movement plan
you're asking like what's the perfect
move to just go for a walk in the sun
outside man like that's what we need and
then we'll figure out
it's not just the strategy it's like
what do you like doing
so as you start talking to people and
doing collaborations or doing interviews
if you interview you message people hey
i'd love to interview you talking about
real estate or talking about nutrition
or talking about movement or talking
about whatever
you just message them like instagram has
just people from the community you just
message them and not
whoever you want some people in the
community some people random like
the more you can make it personal just
like imagine you're sending an email to
somebody
do you only send email to people who you
already know no you can reach out to
other people too you can even
you can even email
like use email instead of instagram as
the outreach and say i want to do an
interview with you
and people might ignore you and people
won't see it and some people will see it
and say yeah let's do something you're
saying to do a combination of me talking
sometimes and some videos also combine
with other people like sometimes it'll
be only me and sometimes
other people and if i understand
correctly
you're saying that the first video
please correct me if i'm wrong the first
video should be like introduction of
what's the goal of this uh channel
doesn't have to be just make a first
video like the first video should be
hey guys
i've been sitting on making videos for a
long time and uh
i'm working on a relationship with
technology but i know i want to serve so
i don't know what i'm
here
doing
go post right like and go like but
there's no it doesn't like release
perfect
it doesn't matter what you do in your
first video alipaz says you can
interview me if you want i'm a movement
with yoga
reach out to ali paz a-l-y-p-a-w-s
there you go you got another one right
it's like
you start and here's the thing as you do
more the reason why i suggest talking to
people is because it it starts to
crystallize the thinking
and
it allows you to make better decisions
going forward like when you say movement
there's so many just look at movement as
an example there's so many things you
could do
right do salsa dance do you go
trampolining do you go skiing do you go
to to a gym do you join a running club
like and there's no right answer
there's a right answer for you
but there's no like one right answer for
everybody
and how do you find it like
don't worry about getting to become a
professional salsa dancer yet
get off the couch and go for a walk
right and like we start to build the
practice in
and so in talking to people what you'll
find is
maybe you want to do more of those kinds
of people and those topics maybe you
talk to ally pause and talk about yoga
and now you like fall in love with yoga
and you want to do a lot more with yoga
and and you create a weekly series
talking yoga doing yoga and it becomes
like a big thing for you or or that was
one and done and like you don't want to
do any more yoga like by doing it
you start to learn if you liked it
and by doing the stuff that you like
then we can work worry about the right
strategy yeah afterwards so i understand
that uh and i do appreciate that you
know what's funny evan when people come
to me it's really like it's easy for me
to tell them this and i think you should
do abcd
it comes to me i'm like yeah you know
what
uh so that's that's kind of funny like i
realized that a few times uh i want to
ask you a question about uh two last
questions because i know there's a time
one is
is anyway like i know you always offer
help to other people like i would love
to know what's what's the way uh
we i'll say i can help you as a person
that's number one and uh number two
uh you talk about the book always bad
belief and believe is
three different types of belief
but my question is evan how do you hope
someone believe in himself when he's in
rock bottom because you know when
someone's running outside and having fun
or dancing salsa with you know
movement so that's fun but when
someone's all the way down like how do
you how do you hope and believe in
himself usually people in that place
won't want even to listen like
i hope i was clear
yeah so
um
you're not going to get somebody
uh to go off and then join a salsa class
like that they're really down um
it's honestly be there with them like if
they're really
i think you have to be if you're at a
ground level then you're ready to grow
but if you're underground then your time
you just have to get back to ground
level this is how i think about it so
there's there's the achievers who need
to push
and it's like they need the honest
feedback to say let's go like build this
and yes it's belief positivity but more
like pushed you gotta go where
somebody who is
below ground right now
they don't they don't need advice
because the advice is only coming off as
judgment
if you tell somebody who's at rock
bottom that they should go and pick up a
salsa class to get moving
it's love from you but it's being
interpreted as judgment
from person tell me what i need to do
they feel it as it's internalized as
judgment even though it's love coming
from you your advice is judgment
it feels as judgment even though it's
not like you're giving love but it comes
across to them as judgment because they
can't hear anything if somebody's
already at ground level ready to grow
it's like hey man how do i grow like i
really need to boost my movement and
you're going to say go do this
they can they're ready for the message
but somebody who's on the ground just
needs to get back to ground level and so
it's sitting with them and listening to
them and just being with them and
letting them feel heard and don't give
them any advice
because you might be the first person to
even ever listen to them
and they might tell you things that
they've never told their spouse or their
parents or their other family members
it's just creating a space for them to
they need to you need to unburden
yourself
from all of the all of the weight that's
on you before you can start to run
and so i wouldn't even worry about what
to say to them don't don't use your
mouth use your ears listen to them
give them a space to be heard
and then you're waiting for them to ask
for help like giving somebody help that
doesn't open anyway
it's just it's judgment it just they'll
they'll feel worse because they feel
like now you're another person is
judging them
so if they're actually at rock bottom
you're just sitting there and listening
to them and being with them
and helping them doesn't someone in rock
bottom want you not of course not always
but sometimes like to throw the rope
that he'll need help or throwing the
rope is basically listening and having
empathy or not empathy i'm not sure i'm
asking
yeah i mean like throwing the rope isn't
isn't the advice you're going to give to
again is just sitting with them
okay
just listening just being allowing them
to be heard
that's that's what they need the most
because nobody everybody in their life
is judging them and telling them what
they should do and they feel like a
piece of garbage
that's what they're telling themselves
and and that person you can't go and and
start dancing with and doing a run with
so it's just it's just being there and
if you're the only person who is around
them who is not judging them and not
tell them what they need to do
and actually just hearing them then what
ends up happening is
they say hey what what do you think i
should do
then you tell them
but
you you're you're opening windows you
have to wait for them to go to the
window right or open the door they have
to go to the door before you can
actually help them and and that's like
here's the problem it feels like it's
not enough
for the achievers when you can see them
you see this huge potential in somebody
and you want to help them build and grow
it feels like it's not enough that
listening alone is not enough
but it's it's it's a tremendous step
it's the exact thing that they need and
it's more than enough and if you can
just focus on like you're judging the
size of the step
you want them to take a giant leap
for them just like an inch forward is a
giant leap
we're judging the size of the step
and so that first step is just listening
listening is amazing
and then in terms of i know i know we're
kind of up on time but you're asking how
can you support me and to believe in i i
you know i appreciate the spirit of that
message um
when a coach gives you advice
the best thing you can do for the coach
is to follow the advice
so
that's the highest form of like if
you're going to help somebody with their
movement and then they go off and they
actually start moving and they write
back to you in three months and say dude
like i did it and look at me now that's
the best form
of
thank you or gratitude more than
buying your book or
whatever else right so
more than
buying anything i'm making
the best way to say thank you or help me
is to do it like start your youtube
channel
contact allypaws and do the yoga gotta
interview together
get things like like that's the and you
know it from the other side right when
people say hey you help me and you did
they did the advice that's that's why we
do what we do
that's the greatest feeling of all time
that's the best way to pay back a mentor
more than
buying their book or course or whatever
else okay consider this as done
what
perfect i appreciate it i love it
and and you're already yeah i mean
you're already doing it you did it here
right you said yes to this
like i've never done instagram live
before i don't even have an instagram
account
your picture is like a beach or
something i don't know what's on there
was amazing
but it's great
and you did it and you're here and you
took the next you took the first step
right and that's the most for movement
that's the most important thing is the
first step
now it's used out of you know once
you're in motion it's easier to stay in
motion
so coach queen kelly and ally pause and
everybody else like reach out and and
started going and that's like the
greatest thing is for you in three
months to say look all here's everybody
that i interviewed and look at my
channel
and look at where it began
that's amazing thank you very much i
appreciate it evan
thanks
tamara's been uh she's part of mover
makers one of our uh members adding tons
of value and tons of love tons of fun
and as part of that we're doing um this
ig live together so
you know how can i help what's going on
what's in your mind what do you need
some perspective
three days
together so
but i can start with 20 minutes that
sounds good
okay evan uh
do you believe
that
um
each one has this power inside them
right
and uh from your belief you send a huge
energy literally huge energy out there
and this energy got me to you
this is how i this is how i met you
okay this is how i came to you because
your energy literally is out there
calling me
and i am here
so out of the belief and the paradigms
and the um
all kinds of
the mindset and all of that
which one do you start
with
as
uh to help someone who has no idea
that he has any any um
power in them or
um like i'm talking about regular people
like myself
before becoming an entrepreneur i had no
idea that i have this power i had i have
a clueless i'm just a mom i spent 20
years with my kids at home just
serving on a small circle
okay i did not know that i have the
power to serve on a bigger level
but i had to make the steps and i worked
on myself to do that now i'm calling all
all people out there
who had the same situation
and i'm telling them come and i'll show
you that there is a better way to live
there is
a way to change your life
okay so here we go where do i start
where do i start event first of all like
it's just adjusting the mindset for
where you're at right like there was a
lot of i am just a in there right i'm
just a mom i'm just where it's like
that's amazing there's a lot of lessons
that you already have that you've
learned that you've grown from that now
you can teach and serve and you know
you've helped your kids grow and learn
and taught them a ton of lessons and now
it's like now how can we be
that influence for other people and be
the mom for the world
um
so
first step is just even just trying to
catch
any of those limiting thoughts anytime
you hear yourself saying i'm just
uh switching out to say hey well i can i
i can i'm ready to do more now that's
where that's who i have been and now i'm
ready to do more and i'm ready to grow
next is every time that you
like the job becomes really about you
just getting better and learning and
improving
and what you said about me was very kind
at the beginning as i put out a massive
energy and you got attracted to that
energy right this is something i was
talking to i'm here at tds i'm at my
dance studio so i own this i'll show you
wow i'm at i'm at this is my dance
studio
we're the with the largest dance studio
in in uh we're for salsa dancing in
canada oh
you gotta
we gotta have a dance
alex and i were just having this
conversation of like planning and how to
play a bigger game and how to grow and a
lot of it just came down to
alex getting better it's the same thing
for use like
every time you learn and you improve and
you get better and you learn something
new
then
it increases the energy with which you
show up
and then people will find you you become
the magnet
and every time you learn something new
you bring other people right i don't
know if you talked about this but like
the staircase of growth every time you
step on the growth you're pulling
somebody up with you to learn
but you know if you're at step three you
can only help people who are step one
and two
and when you get to step 100 you can
help people who are you know one to 99
and so
the goal becomes
to continue to get better and continue
to improve your own energy and your own
self-worth and your own efforts and in
that you will attract people
who see themselves in your story
and feel like huh
you know if samar can do it
maybe maybe maybe i can too
for for all of the moms out there who
are saying i'm just a mom
if samar could become an entrepreneur
and start her business and have success
maybe it's maybe i can too maybe it's
possible for me too
and the more that you tap into that and
believe and create with that with that
spirit and that energy the more you'll
start attracting people who are ready
they can accept you absolutely i i have
this and this is what kept me going i
was like a year ago exactly like today
a year ago
i did not have half of the success that
i have today
because like you know you start working
and on the mindset once one day on a
mindset or like for a while and then i
i say okay now i have to do my paradigm
i have to work on that area
then you know i keep going so i look at
myself i'm like oh i came
away
along the way
i mean for me ago but
all the time i think maybe this is this
is holding me back for sure that how can
like um and i hear it probably all the
time people reach out to me that i
cannot do what you're doing now i cannot
be out there on social media i'm scared
it's
you know fears comes and so
they
people are not moving forward
like people my target people the people
i'd love to help the most
they have so much
holding them back
so
yeah
this is why it's so important to share
your story
because if people look at
you now where people look at me now
they'll say well i could never
i could never do that i could never be
they don't believe that i'm shy they
don't believe i'm introverted they don't
believe
uh and then and then i post i try to
share
as much as i can as often as i can in
sharing the story or in showing the
growth of my youtube channel and how
many subscribers i had after every year
and how long it took to grow because so
many people are ahead of where i'm at
already after their first year like a
lot of people are ahead of me in year
one and me in year five or year seven
and they feel like they're failing it's
like failing
seven years to get there are you kidding
me
it becomes a job to
show behind the curtains and tell your
story and where you've come from because
if you're talking about you know just
being a mom and the growth that you've
had people
you know moms won't connect to me as
much as they will to you
because i'm not a mom right i mean i
have a son um so i'm a father and a
parent i understand that but but i'm not
i don't have the same thoughts or same
issues or same insecurities that you had
that other moms are going through where
they'll love to hear from you
it's not like they won't like to hear
from me but
you can connect with them on a much
deeper level because you
they know exactly what they're going
through yeah and i know that
you you always talk about youtube and
you pushed me already to post to you new
youtube videos and i'm i'm doing this
challenge
to be done with eight more
i mean this is huge for me
you've got you've got uh what's tuesday
you've got two days to get eight videos
out let's go somewhere
okay but something listen this is a
great example because
if you were to share how you felt
about making the video i'm sharing your
head there might have been oh i don't
know how to make youtube video who's
going to watch it how's my hair
uh what's my message going to be how can
i get 10 videos done in a week
any of the like whatever the voices were
that were in your head even if something
like this like going live with with me
on instagram maybe you were scared maybe
you had insecurities maybe you you know
thought hopefully i would cancel i used
to think that all the time like i hope
they cancel on me so i don't have to
show up because i might embarrass myself
like whatever the whatever the negative
thoughts that
you've grown a lot compared to where you
were and they're still
limiting beliefs and there's still
negative thoughts and there's
but the difference now is you try to
catch them and you try to show up for
them so
just because you are afraid to make 10
videos in a week and post them on
youtube and
but letting people know
what your fears were maybe you've never
done youtube before maybe you know all
of the issues that are going on in your
head that maybe two years ago or five
years ago you would have said
oh so i can't do it because i don't know
these things versus samara in 2022 is
gonna say okay i i'm afraid
yes let's go we're gonna do it
and and it's it's
that vulnerability that will attract
people to you because on the surface
what they might only see is your videos
and it you look confident you look like
you know you're talking about it and it
looks easy
and you don't
there are two camps okay there's the
people who make it look easy and there's
a lot of fake underneath it and then
that's how they sell is like hey this is
going to be really easy follow my system
and tools and that's how they get people
in
i'm not as big a fan of that i like to
show hey i still struggle i'm still
insecure i still doubt myself all the
time and
those are not good enough reasons and so
i'm still going to show up
and that's what connects people to you
so you can still use that
on an everyday basis not only share the
story of where you came from but hey
guys hey hey mothers hey ladies today i
was worried today i was nervous today i
was scared to do this instagram live and
i still did it and it and it and it went
great and here's how i show up because i
don't want fear to be a good enough
reason for me to stop
and that's the thing that then connects
people to you and gives them hope
because you now represent you become a
hero to them
that because you had the courage to do
it even if i don't know you i've never
met you but
but in how you show up and your smile
your authenticity and the vulnerability
and you sharing that piece that made you
worried
makes me have a little bit of hope that
you know maybe just maybe
i can do it too yeah that's absolutely
awesome
you know when i first um met evan
on youtube uh he always talked about
how he believes and and new
entrepreneurs startup entrepreneurs and
that was me
you talk to me all the time everything
you talk to me you exactly know how my
brain works literally okay
so and you said you loved entrepreneurs
and and to me got me curious i'm like
okay i'm gonna go and check out myself
really are you the man who really cares
i come in
i see this guy with the huge energy
everywhere movement makers everybody
loves he loves everybody everybody loves
him
the second week and you'll show up with
this crazy idea let's make videos
i'm like who is that guy
who is this guy
that's such a crazy idea
i was so much work not expected it's are
beyond expectation to me and this is
what what what i said about your energy
because that was what i was looking for
literally i was looking to to the my
next step and i did not know where to go
i started my new book i i'm looking to
to start a speaking career and i want to
make youtube videos but where to go i
mean where is the start
and here you go evan you got my energy
you got you got in my head and you said
to me okay go ahead this is your
challenge do it
that's that's how how that's how
powerful is that
that's how how
yeah this is this is amazing
yeah
so thank you it means a lot that we all
want to wake up and feel like what we do
matters even to one person and
you're showing up with amazing energy
and care and kindness and and you know
doing the work and
um i think everybody has
the same level of care and compassion is
like you have it too i'm if i if i'm
special then everybody's special right
like everybody has the desire to serve
and help and care and we can you may not
get energy from the same thing you know
for some people
doing an instagram live or making videos
is depleting of energy and is the worst
thing of all time but but they get
energy from doing something else
and we all want to feel like we're doing
something that's touching somebody
else's life and if you can ever tap into
that you know if you if you want to help
the mothers of the world
you know it becomes this giant mission
to go on you know it's how many mothers
are there out there you know billions um
and it sometimes may feel like it's too
big and there's too many and you're not
good enough and you can't reach that
many people
um and i get that all the time like if
i'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem it's too big a problem
for me to do
uh and so in those moments this well i
can help one person
you know i can i can help one person
and if there's one person that you've
helped with with the piece of content or
an email or message to them
that just lets you have a little bit
more momentum that day and the next day
and carrying to the next week um
i think that's what we all want and the
challenge has been crazy
what
what
one of the things that i've learned that
took me a while to get in you know um i
love that you're so fast on things is as
soon as i got an idea
i would instantly judge it
you know i would say i'm not good enough
or i need i need this to figure out or i
need to get that camera or that gear
it's like you start going into planning
and instantly not even telling your
friends and they judge it it's like i
would judge the idea myself
of how
bad an idea it was or how much i wasn't
ready to do that idea
and as a result i
stayed on the couch kind of just not
doing enough action
where
now i've just learned to bypass it to
say hey great ideas flow through me
if i get an idea i want to do something
on it at least to give it a shot because
you won't know
by thinking about it you have to go off
and do it
and so the challenge is one of those
things where i was going on my walk in
the morning and i just thought of this
idea and for everybody doesn't know i
had this idea for a month-long challenge
it was a lot of work of helping guide
people through
uh creating good titles for their videos
powerful opinions for their videos and
then recording 10 videos and
every day
you're doing this for free basically for
us and this is amazing
it's really this is like
i would pay like literally thousands of
dollars to do to have that it's really
powerful you have no idea the effect on
me as a person as a
as everything in my business in my life
that i got what i want i this is the
path for me and i got it and this is
huge for me you have no idea
well i mean that's why that's why we do
it right i mean just trust the ideas
that come to you and
here's a great point i mean it's worked
out super well in my head i wanted five
people to go and do it with and
something like 40 people completed the
first round
and that was me going back and forth and
back and forth and i'm not doing it
again in this format because it's crazy
right it's too crazy to do it like it's
not sustainable to do it in this format
i might do it around two in a different
format but
you learn by doing and it's been a great
experience and and
uh it's been a lot of work for you and
people who contributed as well as for me
to look at everything that's going on in
my team you know now here's a new thing
we have to keep track of and work on
that they weren't ready for because i
had some idea to pop into my head
and
we'll get a better round two when i do
it again
because of what we learned through round
one but it doesn't make the idea a bad
idea like the idea came to you it's of
service to others go and try it instead
of judging it and thinking about it and
all of the things that come into it just
go and try a version of it and it almost
never works exactly how you want it to
work after the first try
but you make it better for the second
time through and did you love it and so
um it's been great like the feedback's
been awesome you're you know iterating
some of it here and i appreciate you for
that uh and i think all of us just sit
on ideas too long and what i love about
you is like okay you know what that's it
you give it a shot and you go and you
create and you see what happens and
and then you worry about how to make it
good and make it better and make it
sustainable and make it a part of like
you could even if you went through this
process
worst case and you realize you know what
making youtube videos is not for me i
never want to do it again
like if that was the worst case right
like worst case at least you know
because you did it as opposed to just
thinking about it like maybe i should do
that maybe i should do this like this
that was me i was just stuck too much in
like maybe i should do these things and
then a year has gone by and you haven't
done any of those things
and so
more than a year ago i wanted to start
uh youtube videos but the thing is
wherever i go i see those like um all
kinds of music on the videos and the
editing and and this scares me i'm like
i'm not that type so what i'm doing now
i'm trying to make one video no editing
i just go on
and this is huge i know editing and this
is just press on the camera and just
start start talking with that with the
perfect uh
leadership um
help me out that you taught me
yes yeah you have the thought leadership
template
yeah and and listen that's perfect so
like one you've been wanting to make
videos for a year
and didn't and now you have to make 10
in one week
let's go let's go tomorrow let's go and
then also you mean i gave you a template
to follow but
if you don't get it perfect on the first
time who cares right like just keep
going as long as it gets a little bit
better
every single time that's that's the
whole part i mean i made
thousands of videos before i even came
up with that template
so you're already anybody who's in the
challenge is already way ahead of me
like this is stuff that took me
thousands of videos and years to learn
and it's really just
giving yourself permission we don't want
to put something out
that sucks
and it's giving it like but we like why
do you expect your first thing to be
amazing
it's your first time you don't you're
gonna fall as you do your first time
and so giving yourself permission to
to be imperfect
and to create
and to share and
and when you're doing it with other
people it helps too like when you have a
community so i mean having a challenge
you're part of movement makers it's or
other communities so that you're not
doing it all by yourself uh i think
really helps too
um and as much as i've given you you
know energy and strategies you know
you've done the work you know so you're
doing you're doing more than your part
to show up and say hey i'm gonna i want
to show up for myself i want to show up
for my daughters i want to show up for
the mothers of the world here and show
them what what a strong powerful thought
leader woman looks like so i'm i'm
inspired by the action you're taking
i wouldn't have done what you're doing
if i go back to evan at the start of his
journey
i would have been too afraid to join
with makers
i would not have made
10 videos in a week
i would have uh been too afraid to share
like i i don't the whole powerful
opinion exercise i don't have any
powerful opinions i would have judged
myself i would have stopped like at step
one i wouldn't have even taken up the
challenge so
like you're you're way ahead of me
everybody who's doing this i'm inspired
by you guys being at early stages and
and willing to share and put yourself
out there and get the story going
because it took me
like
a decade you know to get any any level
of comfort and sharing anything about
myself
and so you guys but we have you that
you're supporting us here you're making
it short for us i mean i'm here asking
you what should i do shortcut you do
this one two like i don't have to go one
two three then 100 no you show me the
way give me the template i'm like the
way there you go and this makes it
easier the work on me but you show me
that the way and that's perfect
okay well teamwork we're a team we're
doing it together one last thing
okay i'm making you do videos and i want
to be there for so many reasons
i want to keep doing that
uh but i'm not sure if this is the right
for the right place for my audience
because my audience um
they hang out more on facebook and
instagram probably
so what do you think
yeah i mean so facebook organic and now
we're going like strategy right we're
hitting like mindset and energy but
strategy facebook organic is
terrible so facebook is more for
community if you're going to build a
group
i'd still rather you do it in discord
than facebook but uh or facebook is
great for advertisement but facebook
organic for content is is just terrible
instagram is still which i mean we're
doing this on instagram right now
um
it's becoming less relevant
every day
a little bit a little bit a little bit a
little bit a little bit uh youtube is
still for video long form youtube is
still number one there's nothing close
to it your mothers are definitely on
youtube
for themselves and for their kids
you know watching content a lot of kids
like the ipad is the babysitter
so mothers are definitely on youtube it
just depends on the type of content that
you want to make so i would definitely
be looking at
youtube and instagram uh i'd be ignoring
facebook unless you're trying to build
community
long form videos on youtube instagram
short form or lives like this like what
you could do is coaching if you had a
mother come on and you're going to help
her
i didn't know what we're going to talk
about today right he's like we show up
hey samara how are you doing what do you
got for me and and and then we talked
right we didn't script this out there
were no like questions set in advance
and so that's what you could do for
mothers as well is have them come on and
join you and you help them and then
you could cut the video and turn it into
a youtube video and turn into shorter
form content for your instagram so
youtube long form and then instagram
short form and interview or coaching
style videos
that i i'm running uh as a business
coach um i do uh use uh advertising
it's not organically it's i do
advertising this is the
the reach i do by advertising
so ads are great
facebook instagram youtube ads are great
that lead to a business
objective so if it's signed up for your
webinar or buy your book or get on your
email list or whatever you know
in the house hey nina um
gotta gotta always give nina love when
she shows up um
yeah ads are great if you have a
business model attached to it so you're
selling a course or a webinar or book or
speaking gigs or
so great but it's both like if you get
better at organic
that helps with all of your branding and
your conversions as well to create it
just takes more time
you know the the benefit of organic
especially on youtube it takes more time
but it's it's ongoing
and then you don't have to you have to
pay to make the content i guess at the
beginning pay with money but also pay
with
your time
but once you post a video like we're
investing time to do this if i and this
is you know take takes half hour of my
life takes half out of your life
once that's done and it gets edited this
could be a youtube video that then lives
for the next 10 years
that could continue to generate business
if there was a business model attached
to it right
um so
organic definitely supports pay when you
turn paid off
everything goes away
so as long as there's a business model
attached to is fantastic and organic a
lot of people are great at paid are
moving to organic so that they can
develop a more sustainable long-term
model
but
they're both great
if you have a model that works right now
paid is fantastic keep doing it awesome
and now we're building up our brand with
organic content so that you don't have
to spend as much unpaid to get people in
okay it makes sense oh that's amazing
if you want to see me coach another
entrepreneur check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there how do you brand something that is
is challenging for people to understand
you start talking about horses people
think horseback riding people think
seabiscuit don't don't even bring the
horses up
but what are we selling